okay so I just saw the Shazam trailer
iphone quality again trigger this my
house that has almost okay to do a house
tour
I need to do a house tour video she's a
love song okay DC Thank You Warner
Brothers thank you so much this is how
you see this is how you make a video
with anybody where she damn but trailer
looks awesome man
he's like a little kid but some of the
games the powers of Superman it's just
like okay here's what I want to see
because here's what people here's people
want to see from this is a movie
they basically want to see a movie where
someone on the line we end up getting a
version of Shazam who's basically like
the one from Justice League like the
Justice League cartoon show where like
he ends up facing off against Superman
and he's like you guys did you guys
don't know what it means to be heroes
like you guys have forgotten what it
means to be a superhero because like
usually here's the cool thing by Billy
bass here's the cool thing about Billy
Batson is character about Shazam he
brings in a childlike perspective of
superheroes right but like from the
babes of mouth or from the mouths of
babes come truth like it's one of those
things were like he would look at
superheroes and say like you guys are
supposed to be the good guys but your
moral compass isn't supposed to be
questionable you must look like Batman
the only one it's must be questionable
cuz he's Batman he's just like a giant
grump that beats up people in the middle
of night but like Superman you're
supposed to be the good guy Wonder Woman
you're pretty badass or your pool we can
hang like I mean those are those like
all those things like Shazam should be
like you know like like thrown out there
but I think it would be so cool because
it would almost be like Shazam to stand
in for the fan base movies because like
she's any would be like you guys you
guys are superheroes and people would be
like yeah they're padam not like there
are they're dressed like emo kids or
they're like they're like they're like
that was a Dick Grayson from a Teen
Titans trailer I'm so misunderstood by
the world
Justice League look at me that's what
people don't want to see that version of
superheroes and Shazam was never that
way like if you if you go by look at the
oceans and coms very well it kind of
depends on what area you're talking
about I mean you can even go back to
like like whiz comics number two when
you first showed up so you can go back
that far
actually whiz comics number two you got
like a new look at the old Golden Age
comics you look at like the 1950s 60s
was basically I mean sort of Superman
so I mean he was but more often than not
like Billy Batson brought in a kind of
like childlike interest to the superhero
reason why she's an outsourcer man one
of the guys you don't know this alright
this is a little a little bit of a tip a
little bit of a fact here Shazam was
more popular than Superman and I don't
mean like a little more popular I mean
like very popular it was it was crazy so
Superman shows up well you got like you
have the whole Superman mythos
Jerry Siegel Joe Shuster throughout
Superman and then the the president of
Fawcett publications which was just a
news publication at the time goes to
Bill Parker at CC Beck and he says give
me Superman without Superman so they
basically create like Captain Marvel and
that's when it was called back then he
was Captain Marvel and so like like from
there like he hit the stands and it was
like damn he's sort of like gangbusters
dude he blue suit man out of the water
he could fly before she ran dad he had
his first first radio show before
Superman I mean he was out selling the
manage to go by like a margin of two to
one it was it was insane
I wouldn't say that that is peak he was
selling something like 500,000 issues
like as is how much for being sold so DC
super Fawcett and that's what they
that's not even if DC haven't sued the
faucet like super like Shazam will be
the cure is not super with lectures and
be the face of the industry but going
forward into like the future of comics
especially when you're talking about how
basically he disappeared off the radar
for 80 or 15 years that like that and
then came back in the 1970s you were
talking about a very childlike
exuberance that was brought to the
superhero community and people love that
about his in because he was one part
serious one for funny and like dealing
with
like teenage kids do with and and like
reader sitting down and reading stories
like Eliza Shazam just grab that
bullying like throw them into the Sun
like I mean he's a bully the world would
be better off without him but like but
you would read that you say why does it
do that
it was like it was done but this looks
like it's gonna sit down movie where
it's like Superman
it's so dark and so just like you sit
down on this like okay so this is just
like a future in Batman somewhere in the
background which is why everything's so
sad Aquaman featuring Batman in
background by the way black man who
looks over Mary's balls like I'm just
understand like this looks like it's
gonna be fun and it's gonna be
interesting and it's gonna be enjoyable
it's okay so here's one here's how it
feels it feels like it's one part new 52
Shazam one part Shazam power of hope
that's what it feels like it feels like
it's gonna be like those two things
combined together which is gonna be kind
of cool now here's here's what I'm also
kind of hoping there
I wonder if they're gonna throw it in so
back in the early 90s with the Shazam
solo series the last one we had before
they put them in the backup feature a52
um what we ended up finding out is that
when Billy Batson turns into Shazam he's
not turning into this a regular guy he's
turning into how he imagines his father
looks like and siliceous like it's like
dance like a saddest thing ever but I
won if we're gonna go into that like if
they're gonna explain that whole thing
oh yeah trailers amazeballs like it
looks it looks super good I'm really
really excited and I really hope this is
the new town that DC's going for
creating movies like superhero movies a
reflection of the like that's really
looks obese oh my god more strong with
the name I was hoping to see the rock
write like come on be honest y'all I was
kind of hoping that's what we were gonna
see because I want to see like calm doc
I want to see all that stuff like I mean
I'll be honest this makes me excited for
a lot of different things like it makes
me excited for Shazam let me taste some
and I like it'll be DC's chance to
correct Batman vs Superman
they can't undo screwing the pooch
Batman there's no way
what if this movie does Superman it's
gonna be between these two guys you know
I feel like this will be a little hard
in the comics like I'm I'm sorry for
source attitude but it is a very
exciting time because this movie looks
like it's gonna be amazing
it's gonna look like it looks like the
first real superhero movie that DC is
making which which I'm so glad to see so
like do this this movie looks it looks
beast
it looks amaze Falls I was a little
unsure about Zachary Levi when I saw him
wearing like the the muscles too but he
looks badass like Zachary Levi looks
pretty awesome as as Shazam I mean young
and fun and refreshing
that's that's really what we need right
like you don't need everything see 16
year old teenager kid ever won another
superhero movie we need like hey let's
have fun with this because of
superheroes and like who the hell goes
to watch superhero movies to be pissed
off old guys I'm excited I know you guys
are excited post down in the comments
let me know what you guys think